CHARACTER AND THE LEFT WAS ALL
OVER IT.
>> Laura: DINESH, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
AND NOW TO A DISTRESSED MESSAGE
FROM AN OBAMA OFFICIAL AND
FELLOW DEMOCRATS.
FORMER AUTO CZAR STEVE RATNER
THAT THREE OF THE PREDICTION
MODELS SHOW THAT TRUMP WILL WIN
IN 2020.
RAY'S FAIR BILL HIS MODEL
COMBINING INCUMBENCY AND GDP
GROWTH, MARX AND DIG, MOODY
ANALYTICS CHIEF, ANALYZED 12
MODELS.
HE CONDUCTED ELECTORAL COLLEGE
ANALYSIS.
ONE OF THE POLLSTERS, JON
McLAUGHLIN.
ARE THESE HORSE RACE POLLS THAT
HAVE MANY DEMOCRATS BEATING
TRUMP, THOSE ARE ALL THE RAGE A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
WHY ARE THEY WRONG IN THESE
MODELS MORE LIKELY RIGHT?
>> AND A LOT OF THOSE POLLS YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT THE MEDIA
DIES, THEY ARE SKEWED TOWARD THE
DEMOCRATS.
THEY PULL ADULTS, THEY DO NOT
PULL LIKELY VOTERS.
IT'S USUALLY A FEW POINTS SKEW
IN FAVOR OF THE DEMOCRATS.
THESE PREDICTIVE MODELS ARE NOT
POLLS.
IT'S MODELS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE ECONOMY, WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH UNEMPLOYMENT FROM
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH INFLATION.
THE THING IS A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT TO GET REELECTED
WHETHER IT WAS NIXON, REAGAN,
GEORGE W. BUSH, THEY HAVE TO GO
THINGS GOING FOR THEM.
STRONG SECURITY AND ALSO
PROSPERITY, A GROWING ECONOMY.
THIS PRESIDENT'S RECORD HAS A
GROWING ECONOMY, HE'S MADE
AMERICA STRONGER.
YOU CAN SEE -- BY THE WAY, THERE
ARE POLLS, THE MEDIA HIDES
NUMBERS.
CNN HAD A WHOLE WHERE 56% OF
THEIR VOTERS APPROVE THE JOB ON
THE ECONOMY.
>> Laura: JOHN, ALL WE HEAR
FROM FORMER REPUBLICANS, AND
NEVER TRUMPERS WHO HAVE MADE A
LOT OF MONEY BEING NEVER
TRUMPERS, TRUMP'S BASE IS
SHRINKING BECAUSE IT'S JUST A
BUNCH OF ANGRY DISGRUNTLED WHITE
PEOPLE, LET'S WATCH.
>> I'M SO SURPRISED HOW MANY
PEOPLE AT WASHINGTON, THEY DON'T
CARE.
IT'S WHY I'M VOTING FOR HIM FOR
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT HE DOES.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO SAY THAT,
THEY ARE WHITE.
IT'S A SHRINKING ELECTORATE FOR
DONALD J. TRUMP.
>> Laura: WHEN YOU SAY IT LIKE
THIS, IT'S MORE CONVINCING,
JOHN.
>> TERRIBLE.
THIS IS THE SAME STUFF THEY RAN
WITH IN 2016.
>> Laura: THEY WERE WRONG IN
2060 AND FABULOUSLY AFTER THEY
HUNG OUT WITH TRUMP FOR YEARS.
>> THE STRATEGY WAS TO BRING OUT
VOTERS IN THE HEARTLAND FOR
9 MILLION MORE VOTERS WHO CAME
OUT AND ELECTED DOMINIC VOTED IN
THE ELECTION THEN THEY DID IN
2012 AND THEY WERE TRUMP VOTERS
AND THEY TURN THE
COUNTRY AROUND.
WHAT YOU GOT NOW IS A PRESIDENT
IN POSITION -- WE HAVE THIS JOB
APPROVAL.
ONCE HE'S IN 50%, HE'S IN A
REALM WHERE THEY CANNOT BEAT HIM
FOR THEY HAVE 23 DERANGED
DEMOCRATS RUNNING OFF THE EDGE
OF THE EARTH WITH PREFERRING
SOCIALISM OVER CAPITALISM AND
THEY THINK THEY HAVE A SHOT AT
WINNING.
TRUMP HAS A SOLID REPUBLICAN
CONSERVATIVE BASE AND NOW HE'S
GAINING AMONG INDEPENDENTS,
MODERATES, HE'S BUILDING A
COALITION THAT CAN WIN, AND
THAT'S WITH THOSE MODELS.
NONE OF THEM WERE REPUBLICAN
FIGURES, BUT THERE ARE THOSE
MODELS, SHOWING THAT WE CAN WIN.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, JOHN
FEARED WE'VE GOT TO GO.